this is a Dave Landau was on Michael
malice's show and well here you go
they're having a short off
so you're and looking look it came it's
in the middle too so all three of them
officially have left louder with Crowder
I did I left I left a while ago yeah a
little while ago
um I had left
um I think we talked we talked that day
a bit
uh I had had jury duty actually when I
was gonna go back onto the show they had
a [__] Mark you went to jury duty
yeah
and uh they he did give me a nice you
know going away uh
thing you know gift I don't want to get
into it but it was still just it but
they decided not to have me back on I
decided to leave
uh and I walked from the show it was a
long time coming about a year now it was
just through various contract issues and
now it's an odd thing because I wanted
to address it and we had talked about it
a little bit you made a very good point
to me of like I could either bring it up
or have my story be told for me yeah
brilliant cop move brilliant yeah that's
literally a cop move good job Michael I
give him credit for that good job and
um I don't it sucks because I I'm never
one I watched this earlier Michael
malice actually asked a lot of great
questions well let's get to them because
I have 15 minutes so shut up Jesus
people that wants to go out and kind of
it doesn't feel like narking you know
what I mean but it's it's one of those
things where after what happened even
when I left Anthony's show there were so
many people that who drew Anthony yeah
[__] what do you mean when you
[__] screwed over kumias what you
mean you [__] left them high and dry
Michael malice has to know because not
everyone knows who Anthony is everyone
knows what Crowder is well that don't
know me I used to be the co-host there
so many conclusions were drawn to what
actually happened as opposed to what
actually happened
and I don't want people to think that
that there's things that went on behind
the scenes that didn't
yeah so just to fill in the blanks I
think a lot of times and we've all
experienced this on social media I
certainly have when someone doesn't uh
get their story out and there's gaps uh
the audiences will fill in those gaps
for you and leap to all sorts of
conclusions and just kind of create a
narrative that doesn't at all comfort to
reality so a lot of times when it's it a
lot of times I don't always do this but
it's important to be like all right I
don't know I have found this myself to
happen and so on and so forth do you
want to talk a bit about like you know
what led up to this decision on your
part
yeah um I guess the the beginning of it
was uh everything was going pretty well
at the beginning of the show when I when
did you join that show let's talk about
that okay uh I joined the show in
I was first offered February
2001. okay 2001 no 2021. okay
we needed to make America come on man
thought was going to be moving to South
Carolina yeah so uh Stephen had made an
offer to come work for him and I had
been guesting on the show Fairly
regularly so I took him up on that offer
okay
um how did you find it let's let's talk
about that you want to talk about the
end you want to talk about the beginning
how do you want to talk about this
situation
the beginning was great uh for a while
you know it really was it was a lot of
hanging out collaborating when referring
where's the contract stuff yeah that
well and then he I was totally he's like
well that was all options are different
um yeah it's
this is when I had to now start dumping
money into entertainment lawyers so a
lot of the money that I even made on
tour by
right so you know that became another
issue so promotion it says that they
agree to promote your stand up once a
week at a time and at in a medium of
their discretion so it could just be
some random post somewhere that no one
sees
he's right oh they were [__] in a
medium time in a medium I mean I could
just tweet it out can I ask a question I
don't even understand Crowder I'm sorry
man but like if it's one person fine but
it's a lot of people that are having
problems with you every time they go
there's some sort of [__] problems
the only thing I'm seeing is he didn't
make him sign an NDA obviously I think
he's not making people sign ndas anymore
because he got so much [__] for it
before because obviously he's not NDA
he's giving this on the show right
uh oh yeah I'm sorry I I forgot to tell
you so Crowder's um a piece of [__] oh
that's right yeah he's not a good guy
turns out just because they had not been
promoting me okay can I ask a question I
mean I know we do this I know we do this
in a much smaller scale I understand
that
but I I what I don't understand is
regardless if I can never imagine what
size my show is it's my show right it's
not like I have no overlords I don't
have a hard break I could do whatever
the [__] I want right so imagine why
wouldn't you if you had a comic on your
show like oh and a for a year who said
whatever you want about them Jimmy plug
all his [__] dates all the time and
why wouldn't he like it takes like 60
seconds and then let someone plugged I
can't even make Fergie plug your [__]
you remember when uh it got to the um
point where A Serious XM told him he
couldn't plug his gigs anymore yeah so
then they started finding passive
aggressive ways for him to not plug his
gigs on the air and it became like it
was very funny they would weave it into
the stories well yeah it's like well
like next week I'll probably run into
them when I'm at the uh Comedy Cellar uh
Friday and Saturday night right like
they would just find ways to go well we
didn't do we didn't stop the show to
plug his gigs he just works it in the
conversation I don't understand what
what would it matter if at the end of
every episode of crowder you do let them
do a 60 second plug it's not reloading
anybody bro every time you go that's so
scummy every time you go to do real ass
podcast Lewis makes sure that every
single human being in the [__]
building gets a plug at the end am I
wrong yeah does he not go yes do your
plugs boom bang okay uh all right I'm
gonna be at blah blah blah blah check me
out here and then and then Zach does
that hey I'm gonna be here here and here
check me out here blah blah blah and
check me out my other [__] like they
literally do if anything Lewis [__]
realist podcast was it an hour show it's
[__] 15 minutes of plugs at the end
but you know what it's because he's a
good you can get Shannon tells Shannon
like tell him when your show's on like
he makes sure that everybody gets their
[__] [__] in because he understands
that you know what people don't go on
these shows just to go home you go on
and you're like yo tell us where you're
gonna be at tell him where to find you
no but forget that merge merch that's
one thing if it's a guest
he was an employee he was your co-host
no my point was that Lewis does it with
him and said no no I understand the
producer this is even worse than that
because this guy literally works with
you like you understand what I'm saying
like like Lewis plugs everybody no
matter who comes on this now but this
guy's in there every day this guy moved
right I like I've always said I like
land I've never had an issue with Landau
so but but my point is is like why why
you don't have like I don't care if you
like Crowder or don't like Crowder even
people that like Crowder please do the
mental gymnastics make me understand why
you can't give 60 seconds of a show that
you own that has no time there's not a
show coming up next to you you go as
long as you want you go as short as you
want you could take three months off
every year for some weird reason or
whatever
yeah look I like you I don't hate Dave
Landau but I just don't understand his
appeal no no and that's why I don't like
hate the guy or anything no no that's my
point you could not find him funny I'm
not talking about that but he's he's
everything I've heard about him all
behind the scenes is United no he sounds
like a very nice he's a nice guy right
whether you like him or not whatever but
to quote Alec Baldwin and uh uh Glenn
Gary Glen Ross nice guy good go home and
play with your [__] kids well that's
the there's a thing here hey hey hey
that's the thing he wanted to but the
new contract didn't let Lando play with
his kids or go home yeah his contract
got way worse than this and
I put that I would and it's in writing
and what I gave them was I would
actually give them
a commission of my sold out shows okay
uh what
what a scumbag crowd you know
no wonder you make people sign ndas
you're a scumbag for land what a scumbag
for Landau to feel like
he should have to be in a position to
offer that to somebody shows you
what an expectant [__] Stephen Crowder
is and what yeah greedy piece of [__] is
called in a second to say like the
reason why he offered that is because
[__] he couldn't get he couldn't do
any other shows to promote his [__] and
Crowder wasn't promoting his [__] so it
was basically him on his hands and knees
begging Crowder please God promote my
[__] shows dude and a commission of
the shows with an if they were willing
to actually give to actually promote my
shows
your handwriting that I'm looking at yes
it is oh so you said okay I'll give you
guys five percent of the door if I sell
out
uh five percent in general and ten
percent if I sell out okay oh right okay
yeah what the [__] just because I was
where else am I going to go to promote
I'm not on any other shows right and I
don't have time to go to other shows
because I write for him and at this
point I'm now desperate to promote my
shows because of course he won't do it
okay so you have me and Matt McClure
he's got a new daughter we're going
around the country and and I'm watching
ticket sales slide and I'm it's funny
like I'm literally in malls like for
example doing like a funny bone and I'm
in like a comic book store and Matt and
I are standing there and a guy would go
hey you're Dave Landau and I go yeah
he'd be like what are you doing here and
I'm like I'm performing at the Funny
Bone upstairs and he'd be like really
you should mention your dates on your
show and I'd be like yeah I should
you're right wow
it would hurt yeah that was pretty funny
yeah
that is actually really funny there
there is I will say this there is a
charm to just damn that's pretty shitty
to just super honest depressed Dave
Landau is kind of a funny bit yeah
you're right I should be that would be
cool
apparently so not allowing through
Motors dates I when you got into
contract I
what was that about relocating Virgie
just give me a TL here on that I think
he says that in a couple minutes he
mentions that [__] Crowder merch
merch Merch this new contract this new
contract will require Dave to move his
entire family today oh yeah Royce had
told me about this that was in the
[__] contract
yeah with no raise in salary
what though that's the part that bugs me
I wouldn't even care about the because
honestly Dave I also think it's a little
weird that you don't want to live with
your family
um it just seems weird uh as as a father
of two with a and married I understand
it entirely
okay I got that all right that's good I
got that that's good um but I mean it's
just it's just weird that again I would
understand if somebody said look man we
really are going to be working hard
we're going to be ramping things up I
really be more comfortable if you like I
have no problem plugging these shows
helping out I don't want five percent of
your [__] gigs that would never even
ask that of you but it would be probably
better if you weren't flying back every
weekend to shitty Detroit to be with
your family I'll give you a raise I'll
give you relocation money or whatever
but I I would feel better if you were
here and focused on this show and I'm
still not gonna ask you to not go on the
road and do your [__] gigs but it's
just you want to go on the road and do
your gigs and you also want to fly
weekend it's gonna be it's like all
right look here's Crowder has the money
here's a hundred grand
bring your family to [__] taxi you
know what I mean and that would be it
then I would be a kind of on crowded
side I'd be like well yeah why don't you
want to be around your family you're
[__] weirdo but but but you're right
and also no raise that's exactly so I'm
also not getting anything more a year
but you're getting more you're getting
like infinitely more money but I'm gonna
I'm not getting more money take care
of your staff I cannot tell you how
important it is to keep your [__]
staff happy
again smaller scale obviously but take
care of your people let them plug their
[__] plug their [__] when they're live
[__] man go to our [__] locals every
time pass here vergie's honor or any one
of our I try to we always try to Pop
That Then There are twitters hey we read
why not it costs you nothing it cost you
nothing to let Landau plug it but the
problem is when you become someone like
Crowder who needs to monetize every
second every second of his life needs to
be monetized you can't even let somebody
who's on your show do 60 seconds go [__]
yourself Crowder's in a lot of stuff
that we say is cringe and this and that
and now we're kind of figuring out why
not gay Jared had that NDA and now we're
also figuring out that what and after
the especially after the daily wire
thing which by the way now that we
picked daily wireside that was
definitely a patented ROTC hate hate
moment but it but it was Growler strikes
me as the kind of guy that still makes
his wife pick up the tip when they go
out to dinner on a date right you know
what I mean like I'll pay but you know
you should get the tip it's only fair I
don't understand it I don't I don't it
takes it takes a second it takes a
second of [__] Humanity you associate
anything that he's incapable [__]
Canadian sociopath what is wrong with
you Crowder he's a psych I think he's a
psychopath I don't think he's a
sociopath dude everybody that goes on
his show and gets funnier than him he
gets rid of the first was not Kate Jared
Sven computer and now and now landau's
the next one the old bomb you're gonna
have is now you're working with Brian
off quarter black Garrett too it's going
to be tough for you to convince Pete to
get Brewer out of there because Brewer's
already going in there funnier than you
you know what I mean he's already in
there this is gonna I honestly think
this is gonna be my favorite story arc
is gonna be the Crowder Brewer Arc
because Crowder is now not even going to
be the most famous or the most Alpha on
his own show
he hates paying people what they're
worth right and you know he has to pay
[__] good money
to this [__] and he's gonna
start to feel
like threatened and Brewer's the kind of
guy that's like yeah I don't give a [__]
about any of this man I'll [__] I
don't need this money dude you know so
bro we're a [__] Brewer's not going
to put up with [__] from Crowder and
Crowder is going to start getting a
little passive aggressive with [__]
Brewer it's going to be fun it's gonna
be I don't see this this partnership
lasting and I think this might end up
being the most devastating thing in the
crowd and and I really want to
understand from the because there's some
Boomers either going to defend Crowder
no matter what instead of making fun of
us make fun of us we might [__] suck
my only question to you is this is very
simple
do you think what he is doing is right
do you blindly follow Stephen Crowder so
much that you think not letting his
employee have 60 SEC employee and
co-host have 60 seconds to plug his gigs
but costs them nothing is good business
practices do you think making them
reload telling him to relocate his
relocate everything without giving him a
[__] salary you think that's fair
dude he was [__] this dude he was
[__] this dude hard and everybody
knows it and I get you might want to
like Crowder and you're probably the
people that are defending are probably
looking at a at a mug that's collecting
dust as his mug Club on it but to me
it's never been about that I understand
we're on Rumble we know that we're on a
[__] Crowders Turf I understand it we
[__] 100 get it but you want to know
what the [__] difference is when you
look at the bottom of our video you know
what it says join locals you want to
know why because we want everyone to
join locals and we want everybody that
joins locals to join other creators
local so we both are nice big cool
community of cool little shows that
interact and can all hang out it doesn't
say join our [__] ROTC Mud Club
because sometimes it used to be a team
player that way you're not isolated and
everyone used to work with you hates you
what are you doing man forget even if I
don't like you and I I don't know maybe
your dad's not giving you good business
advice but the Optics of this are
[__] horrendous your contracts are
nightmares
yeah dude this this [__] contract
this [__] contract had a clause that
if Dave Landau was more than five
minutes late to work that day
don't leave the building no work no
compensation
Jesus five minutes late McDonald's
employees don't put up with that wait if
they're five minutes late they don't get
paid is that what you just said yes yes
five minutes late to work doesn't get
paid you know what Dave did because what
the contractor looking at in this video
is Dave's that he wrote in [__] and then
sent it back to them and they said no
Dave wrote in 15 minutes
they wouldn't take it
the crowd is a [__] sucker wow amen
whatever dude I don't I don't care if
you like his hot takes or change my mind
this guy this guy from everything I've
seen every time we hear one of these
stories
he's a piece of [__] hey Landau come on
the show
there's some dirt on that Crowder hey
hey Lando guess you could plug all your
[__] over here boy come on
uh
uh whatever man I mean I we don't have
to keep playing anymore I just just
come on man